this video is brought to you by squarespace from
websites and online stores to marketing tools and
analytics squarespaces the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and run your
business check out squarespace through the link
in the description below more on them in a bit
the history of madagascar is rich in stories of
conquest piracy colonial struggle and charismatic
monarchs amongst one of the best known characters
of this epic is queen ranavalona the first who
ruled the powerful marina kingdom from 1828 to
1861. a quick look into her past will reveal
how she protected the independence of her islands
from the influence of colonial powers but it will
also highlight the ruthlessness of her actions
believed to have caused 2.5 million deaths
titles often associated were there include the
mad queen the female caligula or the bloody mary
of madagascar it must be said that most of what
we know about ranavalona we know it through her
enemies so a healthy pinch of salt is definitely
advised nonetheless in today's episode we're going
to do our best to learn about the multiple
facets of this ruler what he became famous
thanks to dramatic acts of bloodshed but had a
soft spot for bureaucracy and data processing
early accounts of ranavalona's childhood are
scarce and contradictory she may have been
born in 1788 or 1790. at birth she may have been
named remarvo according to some stories she was
a commoner of humble origins according to others
she may have been the daughter of prince andrea
that is an extremely long name that i can't
pronounce is cousin what is certain is that
she was born in the marina kingdom the largest
and strongest of the national entities which
composed madagascar at the time additionally
most accounts agree that her father thwarted
an assassination plot against the prince oh when
prince unpronounceable became king he rewarded
his savior by adopting remarvo as his own daughter
who he then betrothed to his son prince radamer in
a slightly less incestuous version of the tale
the young girl was adopted by raleigh soka the
king's sister in 1810 radhara descended to the
throne aged only 18 but his young wife remarvo
was not automatically the queen the girl
now known as ranibal owner had to contend
with the prince's affections of another 11
wives she may have been his first wife but
she wasn't at all his favorite the two never had
a close relationship and ranavalona never bore
a royal child her situation had caught in other
words was rather shaky meanwhile outside of the
royal palace radama was accumulating successes
in 1820 he signed a commercial treaty with the
british empire which secured military equipment
and training for his growing professional army
at the head of his troops the king expanded
the marina kingdom taking over almost all of
madagascar then he established a collaboration
with the london missionary society who opened
schools spread literacy and converted many locals
to christianity finally the modernizing monarch
brought an end to the slave trade a business which
had greatly profited marine aristocracy in the
past this drive for reforms definitely benefited
the military power of the king but redama was
not without opposition when he modernized the
army he ordered all of his soldiers to keep
their hair short demonstrations erupted led by
traditionalist women who wanted to reclaim the
ancestral right to braid the long hair of their
warrior husbands rodama would not have any of that
he ordered for the leaders of the revolt to be
brutally slain and their remains to be fed to wild
dogs further opposition simmered in the shadows
ultra-traditionalist aristocrats who grumbled
against his apertures to european powers and
christian missionaries this may be why his death
in the summer of 1828 is regarded as suspicious
according to one version the king had been
poisoned by his own wife ranavalona in cahoots
with the traditionalists more realistically redama
had fallen out with syphilis or cirrhosis and was
suffering so badly that he cut his own throat rana
bellona now had to make a decision disappear
quietly into the night or fight for succession
the rival heir to the throne was prince rakhitobi
eldest son of redharma's eldest sister he had been
educated in england and was attuned to the late
king's pro-western policies but rakhitobe knew
that the claim was not 100 safe according to
the marina belief system any child of ranival
owner would have taken precedence even if born
after adam's death and even if realistically not
conceived by redharma according to some accounts
ranavalona was indeed pregnant at the time and not
with remedy's child she feared the urakitobi may
attempt to assassinate her and knew that offense
was the best defense the widow occupied the royal
palace and rallied supporters to her cause the
ultra-conservative aristocrats and officers
from her home village all came to her defense
with her back covered ranavalona declared herself
queen of the marina on august 1 1828 claiming that
this was ramada's wish the following june 1828 the
queen underwent a double ascension in which she
would set the tone for a reign divided between
modernity and return to ancestral customs in
a public coronation ceremony she wore a splendid
gown fashioned by a french tailor but in a secret
ride she was anointed with the blood of a freshly
slaughtered bull by the time she performed both
rituals she had successfully got rid of all
claimants to the throne her nephew rakitobe
had been gored by a spear his mother had been
starved to death most of their relatives were
also executed according to biographer keith laider
thousands of suspected opposers met a similar fate
in a show of force designed to consolidate her
as the ultimate ruler this she made clear to her
subjects with a coronation speech never say she is
only a feeble and ignorant woman how can she rule
such a vast empire i will rule here to the good
fortune of my people and the glory of my name
the ocean shall be the boundary of my realm
and i will not see the thickness of one hair
of my realm all right we'll get back to today's
video in just a minute but first here's a word
from today's video sponsor squarespace now more
than ever people are getting creative with their
time they're reaching into their savings account
to start a new business or launch a blog or a
website something like that and the world is
yours with squarespace it's the platform to
use when you're ready to get started on the next
web project that you've been thinking about you're
looking to get in and out quick without thinking
too much about what your website should look like
bam use one of their quick beautiful templates
to make a website that's fresh and for you
like it's right out of the box or maybe more of
a hands-on person you got lots of opinions and
ideas about what exactly your site should look
like squarespace gives you all the customization
options you could ever want with no updates no
patches no technical nonsense to worry about
once you're done setting up your website tinkering
with the design if you're so inclined or maybe
playing around with the colors there are many
extra features that squarespace provides so
that your website can thrive email campaigns
patronage portals social integrations member
only areas analytics commercial opportunities and
customer support everything you'd ever want is in
one place so when you're ready to get started
on the next project of yours big or small if
it involves a website you've got to do it with
squarespace right now you go to squarespace.com
for a free trial and when you're ready to launch
your new site go to squarespace.com forward slash
biographics to save 10 of your first purchase of
a website or a domain and now let's get back to it
some biographies claim that the queen quickly
undid most of radama's reforms she severed
ties with the british and restored local forms of
worship against christian influence but in reality
the shift was not quite so clear-cut according
to british diplomat and historian mervin brown
during the first months of her reign ranavalona
acted entirely out of pragmatism this meant
that she oscillated between continuity with
the late king's pro-british policies and a
traditionalist agenda as she saw more fit and
advantageous ways to consolidate power for example
on the 28th of november 1928 the queen denounced
the anglo-marina treaty of 1820 and on the 25th of
march 1829 she expelled the british diplomat agent
robert lyle but at the same time she entertained
a good relationship with the christian
preachers of the london missionary society
or lms they were allowed to hold mass convert
locals celebrate sacraments and run schools
in exchange a community of expat artisans
attached to the lms made themselves useful by
setting up workshops to manufacture soap
hydraulic machinery and even gunpowder this
last contribution was particularly well received
in october of 1829. from a capital antananarivo
the queen had to contend with the double threat a
rebellion of the sacalava people in the west and
a french invasion on the east coast the french
colony in reunion ireland depended heavily on
cheap labor and supplies imported from madagascar
a steady supply which was interrupted by the queen
in 1829. when the betsy masaka people revolted
in eastern madagascar french king charl the
tenth took the occasion to punish those pesky
marinas by ordering an attack on the port town
of tos messina and mahavillona the invaders
however were first weakened by malaria and
then met fierce resistance from the malagasy army
in july 1830 a revolution toppled shall the 10th
and the new monarch louis philippe was less keen
on expensive colonial adventures eating british
pressure the french withdrew exactly one year
later this was a great victory for the queen
an image and confidence booster but the war had
disrupted trade on the east coast of her kingdom
which relied heavily on the export of cattle and
rice to mauritius and reunion those goods were
sold against hard foreign currency which could
be reinvested into the purchase of firearms
ammunitions the queen was now short on income and
less cash meant less musket balls and who could
tell if the french were to return this is when
the monarch developed a talent for bureaucracy
which may not make for internet headlines but it
surely helped her economy first she developed an
efficient network of civil servants on the east
coast but the stroke of a pen most of the military
officers in the region were appointed portal
authorities with powers to regulate trade then
she issued precise frequent regular instructions
to these officers relying on the written word
which was a departure from the practices of
marina kings who used to issue orders orally
during official assemblies the portal authorities
were instructed to attract new foreign buyers for
their cattle and rice when possible they were to
ask payment either in foreign currency or directly
munitions to stock the royal garrisons the next
step was to regulate imports ranavalona knew
that dependency on imports for basic goods could
leave her country at the mercy of european powers
therefore she ordered her civil servants to limit
imports to the strictly necessary and to pay for
these in local currency or by bartering with
local goods as these practices took hold the
queen established a two-way communication flow
she was informed at all times of all the levels
of production of local goods as well as the levels
of import for the same commodities this data was
centralized and processed by the queen herself
who was able to impose maximum quotas for imported
merchandise the centralization of economic policy
clearly required a tight grip if not an iron fist
ranavalona would realize almost immediately if
decentralized officers took advantage of her
physical distance and issued decrees on their
own accords if a bureaucrat dared to deviate
from her policies he may expect a message like
this one i have the sole authority to make law
through my words if you attempt to speak in my
name your words will return to me like a bird of
great destruction you will be tried and punished
or this one is even better though i'm far away
i stand like a sentinel over you and with that
i think we found our new out of office reply
after the east coast was pacified the queen's
relationship with the lms and the british
community began to sour in november of 1831 she
issued a ban on sacraments no more malagasy could
be baptized and those who already were could
not take part in the holy communion then her
governor cracked down on the christian schools
boys as young as 13 were taken away from class and
most of them were enlisted in the army the
lms feared for a complete closure of their
educational programs but the queen reversed her
policies it seems like she was more interested in
beefing up her infantry rather than damaging the
well-run schools and in the following years the
number of pupils increased from 2 500 to 4 000.
it appears from then on that the interplay between
the court and the christian faith was to follow a
series of wild mood swings influenced by the most
senior aristocrats in the traditionalist party a
watershed moment was the case of reynet zadonava a
christian man who had begun preaching an inspiring
message according to him christ would soon return
to set everybody free and abolish slavery court
officers interrogated him and his followers
and when he stated that a slave was the equal
of the queen the soldiers didn't like that one
bit the preacher and his followers were placed
head down in a pit and killed by pouring boiling
water over them the ultra traditionalist party
continued to feed the queen similar stories of our
christians undermined her authority and scorned
the traditional marine religion wanaka mentions
that on hearing these stories the queen was so
grieved that she vowed death to all christians
on the 26th of february 1835 she sent a message to
the missionaries malagasy could and would not take
part any longer in any form of christian worship
but missionaries and their friends could stay
if they had any useful knowledge or craft to
impart then on the 1st of march the queen issued
a proclamation ordering strict deterrence
to ancestral customs all malagasy who were
baptized who had been praying to the christian god
or who simply knew how to read had to come forward
and recant their faith around this time the queen
had realized that a french invasion was no longer
a threat moreover she had welcomed to court a
useful ally a shipwrecked french engineer called
jean-labord another rumored lover the advisor had
a broad grasp of mythology and munitions with the
queen's backing he directed the construction
of mantasso a factory town on the forefront
of an ambitious program of industrialization
with madagascar heading to self-reliance the
queen could finally do without the missionary's
support and could fulfill the anti-christian
policies favored by her supporters another factor
which may have caused the change in direction was
a shift in the balance of power behind the scenes
in the first two years of her reign the queen was
heavily influenced by her young prime minister
and lover andream heyer who by the way may or
may not have been the father of the queen's
son rakoto the prime minister was a supporter
of king radamus's previous policies and therefore
friendly to the missionaries and open to british
influence but andrea m heyer had powerful enemies
an extremely conservative faction headed by three
brothers of the anda farvaratra family two of them
were also rumored to be lovers of the queen so it
may have been the result of a power struggle or
plain jealousy that this faction conspired to
eliminate angean hire when the minister was
accused of betraying the queen with another woman
he was forced to undergo the trial of tangina but
he preferred to have his throat pierced by a spear
we should now clarify what tangina was this was
one of the many brutal practices instituted by
rana malone and or her supporters as she tightened
her grip against ascension basically if someone
was suspected of opposing the queen they were
forced to take a poison extracted from the
tangena nut which induces vomiting then they had
to swallow three pieces of chicken skin if they
vomited up all three pieces of skin they were
considered innocent but if they died from the
poison well that was taken as proof of guilt and
if they survived but did not threat the skins
they were also considered guilty and they were
executed according to historian gwyn campbell
this form of trial claimed a hundred thousand
lives in 1838 alone another brutal custom
imposed by the ruler was torture by progressive
amputation a brutal fate imposed especially on
non-ethnic mariners who also regularly suffered
from pillaging and abuse from the army the most
common form of mistreatment was the traditional
practice of fana pawana forced labour for those
subjects who could not afford their taxes the
poorest among the malagas who were pressed into
service as builders foot soldiers or litter
carriers for the aristocracy ravanalona had
effectively reinstated slavery causing thousands
of deaths due to starvation exhaustion and disease
christians were of course also a common target for
elaborate punishment in 1836 the army apprehended
14 malagasy christian leaders who had resisted
orders to give up their religion rad abalone
ordered them to be dangled by ropes over a rocky
ravine the ropes were then cut and the martyrs
plummeted to their deaths as he is progressed the
queen further descended into a downward spiral of
morbid grotesque holly the buffalo hunt of 1845
is often cited as an example on that occasion
ranavalona ordered her entourage to take part
in a large buffalo hunt dragging along thousands
of slaves and servants the whole party numbered
some 50 000 people who built roads burnt wood and
leveled villages to make way for the queen
and her aristocratic friends as the expedition
marched on searching in vain for elusive buffalo
starvation and malaria took their toll according
to keith ladler in total 10 000 men women and
children are said to have perished during the
sixteen weeks of the queen's hunt in all this time
there is no record of a single buffalo being shot
around the same time rana bolona had firmly
decided that her island should be rid
of all foreigners on the 13th of may 1845 she
passed a new law ordering that all foreigners
should perform unpaid labor in the execution of
public works the expat community understandably
refused the order and they were therefore ordered
to leave madagascar within 11 days british traders
in tamida on the east coast sent a letter to the
governor of the british colony on the island of
mauritius venting their grievances captain kelly
of hms conway was sent to investigate alongside
two french vessels the bear saw and the zolay the
french decided to launch a punitive expedition
and kelly was game the combined anglo-french force
attacked the fort of tamadave on the 15th of june
reassured by the flimsy looking defenses when they
realized that the weak palisades were just a decoy
it was too late the well-trained marine army had
concealed their real barricades behind a decoy
fort and launched a counter-attack the british and
french marines suffered 21 dead and 53 wounded and
hastily fled back to their ships at the end of the
day 21 skulls of the dead marines were impaled on
spikes warning europeans against further invasions
the queen may have imposed a regime of terror but
so far she'd succeeded in protecting her realm
from colonial rule all while radovalona's son
prince rokoto had grown into a well-respected
young man who distanced himself from his mother's
policies he did not approve of summary justice
execution by chicken skin or disguised slavery he
became popular among the malagasy as he released
prisoners and donated food to foot soldiers
in the early 1850s rokoto had become good friends
with a french businessman jose francois lambert
who had become affluent in mauritius thanks
to the slave trade lampara had been invited
to court after an incident in which he had saved
with his ships and marina soldiers surrounded by
rebelling farmers lambie had become very wary of
the queen's brutal policies in 1854 he and drakota
began plotting a coup to overthrow ravallona
on the 28th of june 1855 the two conspirators
signed a secret agreement the frenchman committed
to garnering support to their cause in europe
in exchange he would get the sole right to
exploit all minerals forests and vacant estates
in madagascar rocoto agreed to receive only ten
percent of the profits the next step was to invite
foreign intervention amber wrote to french emperor
napoleon iii inviting him to invade and establish
a protectorate in later years the junior bonaparte
would be eager to stick his fingers in countless
colonial pies but at that time he was influenced
by the sassamore school of foreign policy which
stressed indirect rule and catholic missionary
activity over military intervention undeterred
lambert embarked for a tour of europe seeking
to obtain political and military support to
defeat rana bolona and her army but in 1857 he
returned to the island empty-handed as a last
resort ricotta and lambert enlisted help from the
queen's advisor and possible lover the shipwrecked
engineer labored they finally decided to set the
coup in motion but it was a total disaster the
queen always kept well informed by her network
of spies she knew all along what was coming but
toyed with the conspirators giving them a false
sense of security at the last moment she struck
arresting all the participants except for lambert
who escaped alive rikoto and lambord were spared
but everybody else was sent on a forced march
across swampy islands and most died from malaria
once again queen ranavalona the first triumphed
unscathed and she would remain untouchable until
the 16th of august 1861. this is when to the
frustration of her enemies the sovereign died
peacefully in her sleep at a funeral a barrel of
gunpowder went off accidentally killing several
mourners a fittingly violent end to a violent
reign the queen was succeeded by rocoto who took
the style of radhama ii his rule was short-lived
as he was assassinated only two years later
madagascar entered a period of steady decline
marked by increasingly weaker rulers a period
which ended with a successful french colonial
invasion in 1896. today ravenolona's legacy
is divided and divisive even in madagascar a
tenure in power is remembered by some as the
darkest period in the island's history or by
others as an age of prosperity solid economic
policies and effective resistance against foreign
invaders it doesn't help that many of the stories
which concern the queen may or may not be true if
you pale from that beautiful country please let
us know in the comments your thoughts about
today's protagonist was she a parmad tyrant
or a model of self-determination against the
excesses of colonialism and just before we
leave today right at the beginning of today's
video we said some people have compared it to
bloody mary the blood contest we've got
a video all about her elizabeth bathory
which i will link to on the screen now and
i'll see you next time now just before you
leave today maybe looking for something else to
watch why not check out my new channel called wara
graphics want to know all of the details about
some of history's most famous battles and wars
come join me on war of graphics from sherman's
march to the sea to operation barbarossa it's
got people fighting each other or occasionally
animals we will cover it there is a link below